[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation pour accompagner sa
stratégie souveraineté la france a
développé depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale une capacité militaire de
défense et de projection s'appuyant sur
une force de dissuasion nucléaire
maritime et aérienne permettant de
répondre à toute attaque
elle est actuellement la première
puissance de l'union européenne tant par
le niveau d'investissement que par la
capacité opérationnelle
elle le prouve tous les jours en afrique
mais là également montré dans le cadre
de l'otan et en afghanistan en libye ou
encore en syrie
cette stratégie de puissance lui a
permis de garder jusqu'à maintenant son
siège au conseil de sécurité
malgré la baisse régulière de son poids
économique
elle repose sur une armée
professionnelle reconnue comme très
performante et sur une industrie de
l'armement très compétitive qui fournit
un matériel efficace aux armées de terre
air et mer pour en maintenir le niveau
et la qualité
les industriels avec l'aide de l'état
via la délégation générale à l'armement
doit financer une recherche de pointe
qui a ne faut pas l'oublier des
retombées dans de nombreuses autres
activités et une production dont le coût
baisse avec la quantité produite comme
les commandes de la défense française
sont insuffisantes pour assurer les
équilibres financiers des produits
il faut vendre impérativement une partie
de ceux-ci à des pays étrangers ce qui
nous met en concurrence avec les autres
grands pays producteurs
durant son mandat le président entre
hommes s'étant plaint du peu
d'investissements européens dans le
domaine de la défense
en dehors de l'angleterre et de la
france a exigé que le budget militaire
des principaux pays atteigne un minimum
de 2 % du produit intérieur brut
il est vrai que la plupart faisant
confiance à l'otan donc aux américains
pour assurer la protection de l'europe
face à l'union soviétique est maintenant
à la russie ont préféré investir dans le
développement économique
et ce fut particulièrement vrai pour
l'allemagne qui n'avait pu reconstituer
une armée qu'en novembre 1955
mais depuis dix ans pour rattraper son
retard
ce pays a augmenté son budget deux fois
plus vite que la france et l'injonction
du président trump l'a motivé à
accélérer encore cette montée en
puissance
c'est ainsi qu'en 2020 son budget de
49,3 milliards d'euros contre 50,1 pour
la france et qu'en 2021
il sera de 53,3 milliards d'euros alors
il est vrai qu'en pourcentage du pib
il est encore autour de 1,5
quand la france est proche de 2%
compte tenu du poids respectif
économiques des deux pays
quand ils atteindront les fameux 2 % le
budget mis littéralement sera très
supérieur au nôtre
pour le moment selon les think tanks
cyprié est hs markit
la france a renforcé sa place de
troisième exportateur d'armes au mondial
sur la période 2016-2020 elle a une part
de marché de 8,2 pour cent dont 45% dans
le domaine aérien et 17% dans le domaine
maritime
ajoutons que 48% nos exportations
d'armements vont vers le moyen-orient et
36 % en asie-pacifique
comme le rappelle vincent lamigeon dans
challenges ce secteur qui a généré en
2019 un excédent commercial de 8,3
milliards d'euros est un des trois
meilleurs de l'industrie française à
l'export
avec l'aéronautique et l'ensemble chimie
parfums et cosmétiques
il est donc vital non seulement pour le
maintien de notre capacité de défense
mais aussi pour réduire le déficit
inquiétant de notre balance commerciale
la france a été à l'origine du traité
sur le commerce des armes
adopté en 2013 par l'onu elle ne devrait
donc vendre du matériel de guerre qu
pays respectant les droits de l'homme
ceci explique pour partie les critiques
répétitives des politiques et des
associations allemandes contre notre
politique d'exportation en contrepoids
il est intéressant noté que l'allemagne
avec une part de marché mondiale de 5,5
pour cent est pas mal et un des trois
seuls pays avec la france et les états
unis à avons augmenté les siennes entre
2016 et 2020 on peut s'interroger sur le
double langage qui consiste à critiquer
la france pour ses ventes d'armes en
arabie saoudite tendant qu'elle réalise
23 % de ces bornes d'armement au
moyen-orient dont des sous marins à
l'egypte on doit se questionner quant à
l'agressivité des actions menées par le
concurrent allemand contre le français
navale groupe lors de la négociation du
cotre australien pour des sous marins de
type barracuda
à force de nous regarder avec
satisfaction
nous ne voyons pas ce qui se passe chez
nos voisins la france pourrait perdre
son leadership au sein de l'union
européenne dans le domaine de la défense
conventionnelle
dès cette année car notre budget actuel
inclut également la force de dissuasion
évalué à 6 milliards et le financement
des opérations extérieures
cette réalité est confirmée par le
passionnant rapport réflexion sur la
bundeswehr de l'avenir
signé par la ministre anne grete grande
car npower le chef des armées le général
eberhardt zone il annonce clairement
selon johanne et stern dans wsws pointe
du 17 février
la volonté de l'allemagne d'avoir la
première armée de l'union européenne du
fait de sa position centrale afin d'être
en capacité de pouvoir intervenir
militairement dans toute l'union
nous sommes donc en train de vivre un
bouleversement militaires majeures qui
explique les positions actuelles des
deux principaux protagonistes de l'union
européenne pour sauvegarder leurs
positions les français comptent sur la
qualité de la relation franco allemande
mais notre gouvernement s'appuie sur une
coopération qui tient de plus en plus du
voeu pieux et deux moins en moins de la
réalité avec la crise sanitaire
la france a subi sur la période 2020
2021 une baisse du pib d'au moins cinq
points de plus que l'allemagne soit deux
à trois ans de retard de croissance
comme je l'évoquais dans une émission
précédente nos voisins bénéficieront en
plus une capacité de relance très
importante
financé à 50% par leurs réserves
financières
chez nous cela passera par une
augmentation de la dette déjà abyssale
dont les pays du nord exigeront la
réduction comme nous l'avons fait nous
mêmes dans le passé pour la grèce et
l'italie avec cet écart économique
qui s'élargit sans cesse l'attelage
n'est plus ce qu'il était comme on l'a
vu lors de la signature du traité entre
l'europe et la chine sur lequel la
france avait exprimé des réserves
qu'elle a oublié quelques jours plus
tard pour signer un côté de la
chancelière
on vient d'en avoir la confirmation
quand la france a critiqué la hongrie
achetant le vaccin russe foot nique pour
se taire quelques semaines plus tard
quand angela merkel a annoncé qu'elle
envisageait de faire de même pour le
bien des allemands
chacun sait que le président de la
république
ardent défenseur de l'union européenne
rêve de développer une europe de la
défense à côté de l'otan qu'ils
considèrent en état de mort cérébrale le
problème c'est que cette idée rejetée
par tous les pays du nord de l'est ainsi
que par l'italie est inacceptable pour
les allemands il nous rappelle que le
président sarkozy en décidant notre
réintégration dans l'organisation de
l'atlantique nord le 7 novembre 2007 a
mis en application l'article 42 7 du
traité de l'union européenne qui
rappelle les engagements souscrits au
sein de l'otan qui reste pour les états
qui en sont membres
le fondement de leur défense collective
et l'instance de sa mise en oeuvre
comme le signale jacques billard dans
boulevard voltaire le point final a été
écrit par ville frites band rénove
spécialiste politique allemand de la
défense dans le figaro du 12 mars
dernier
la réalité est que si les allemands doit
choisir entre l'europe et l'otan ils
choisiront toujours l'otan ceci permet
de mieux comprendre dans quel cadre et
avec quelle limite se situe la
coopération militaire avec notre pays un
bon exemple en est donné avec le coup
d'arrêt au programme mavs lancé
conjointement en avril 2018 par les deux
ministres de la défense pour développer
un nouvel avion de patrouille maritime
devant remplacer en 2030 les p 3c orion
des allemands et les atlantiques te des
français devenu obsolète
conçu comme le centre d'un réseau de
capteurs de tous ordres il devait
apporter des capacités accrues en
matière de guerre électronique de lutte
anti-sous-marine et d'armements y navire
mais la semaine passée l' agence chargée
des exportations américaines
d'équipements militaires la ds ca a
rendu un avis positif sur la vente à
l'allemagne de cinq avions de patrouille
militaire p-8a poseidon et d'un boeing
737 militarisé afin de permettre à cette
dernière de maintenir sa capacité pour
les 30 prochaines années en remplacement
des huit patrouilleurs de la marine
allemande
elle précise en plus pour le congrès
selon le site opex 360 que ce projet de
vente viendra appuyer la politique
étrangère et la sécurité nationale des
états unis
en améliorant dans l'otan la sécurité
d'un allié important pour la stabilité
politique et économique en europe
alors pour sauver le programme et 138
croire les français propose de prêter 3
atlantique 2 pour remplacer les ps3
c'est orion mais que penser d'un
partenaire qui sans prévenir achètent à
l'étranger le matériel que l'on devait
construire ensemble
il est vrai qu d'assaut n'obtenant pas
la maîtrise d'oeuvre s'est retiré du
projet qui a pris deux ans de retard
reportant d'autant la livraison du
premier avion de la série mais ce
mauvais coup a été préparée de longue
date puisque les allemands avaient déjà
raccourcie unilatéralement de cinq ans
l'échéance du délai imparti
dans son audition à l'assemblée
nationale le 17 mars le général
eberhardt forme a précisé que
l'allemagne n'a pas besoin d'attendre
vingt ans pour pouvoir répondre à ces
besoins capacitaires il a précisé
regarder ce qui existe sur le marché et
ce que nous pouvons acheter tout près et
lorsque nous ne le trouve en bas nous
lançons éventuellement un projet de
développement
c'est une politique logique dans le
cadre de l'otan mais très différente de
la nôtre cherche en permanence à
préserver et améliorer nos capacités
pour préserver notre souveraineté sur le
matériel militaire de surcroît la
coopération est difficile par suite des
différences d'approché entre les
industriels des deux pays
les difficultés du scaf c'est à dire le
système de combat aérien futur en sont
une belle démonstration
nous sommes obligés de collaborer car
même en possession des capacités
technologiques personne en europe ne
peut développer et financer tout seul un
chasseur de la prochaine génération dans
un excellent article de la tribune
michel cabirol confronte les
déclarations du président d'aso et celle
d'antoine bouvier directeur de la
stratégie d'airbus pour celui ci habitué
à gérer la coopération internationale
lorsqu'il était président du missilier
mba les incompréhensions entre les deux
pays et les deux industriels
proviendrait d'une différence du modèle
de coopération entre dassault aviation
et le modèle allemand prônée par bus le
modèle français est celui d'un maître
d'oeuvre fort qui contrôle les risques
et prend des responsabilités sur le
programme lui même est utilisé sous
traitants le modèle allemand repose sur
le partenariat au même niveau d'acteurs
qui ont une maîtrise d'oeuvre commune et
se répartissent de façon égale les
charges de travail
si ces différences fondamentales
expliquent les problèmes actuels du scaf
et se rencontrer à l'époque de la
séparation entre le rafale est
eurofighter elle explique aussi les
problèmes de retards et de mise au point
rencontrés avec l'a400m
l'expérience montre que dans tous les
cas de figure les programmes sont livrés
en retard et dépasse le budget initial à
la différence des produits achetés sur
étagère
il ne faut pas croire que l'égalité la
norme quand les allemands sont les
leaders d'un programme
dans le cas du char du futur où il
devait y avoir un équilibre entre les
parties la partie française de cas nds
et nexter ont pu constater à leurs
dépens que les allemands avaient
récupéré la quasi-totalité de la
maîtrise d'oeuvre en réalité dans tous
les cas de figure celui qui maîtrise
l'essentiel des technologies ne veut pas
les partager avec d'autres pour
préserver son savoir-faire ses brevets
et son avantage concurrentiel
mais le programme mgc s1 même gars
nkamba de systèmes dont les études ont
commencé depuis l'été 2020 fait aussi
émerger un autre problème celui de la
finalité d'utilisation de larmes
il est difficile d'imaginer quelle sera
la composante l'ourthe dont les deux
armées auront besoin en 2035 2040 et
comment le char se positionnera dans ce
contexte sur le mgc est ce toujours
selon michel cabirol les observateurs
ont l'impression que l'approché actuelle
est différente entre les français qui
veulent un système disruptif et les
allemands qui souhaitent simplement un
léopard améliorée toute la difficulté va
être de les mettre d'accord sur un
programme commun
construit sur des compromis acceptables
comme le rappellent les sénateurs roland
le gleut hélène conway mouret il existe
des divergences fondamentales entre les
ambitions militaires de la france et
celle de l'allemagne
pour eux la priorité allemande repose
presque exclusivement sur la protection
du territoire et de la population
nationale dans une défense collective du
périmètre européen tandis que la france
identifie davantage des menaces sur des
théâtres éloignés comme pouvant avoir
des répercussions nationales
en définitive quand les allemands
veulent un simple chasseur de défense
aérienne les français pensent à un avion
de combat polyvalent capable de se poser
sur un porte-avions et d'emporter la
composante nucléaire
leur mission ne se recoupant donc
partiellement
il faut trouver un équilibre liées aux
besoins et à l'expérience opérationnelle
rares sont les cas d'une arme
indispensable comme l'hélicoptère de
combat tigre
le chef d'état major de l'armée de terre
le général thierry burckhart dans une
longue interview dans la tribune a
rappelé que pour être une armée de
premier rang en europe
il faut être capable de faire de la
haute intensité ce qui demande une
composante aéro combat intégrer elle
doit rester à un niveau technologique
suffisant pour pouvoir être engagée et
produire des effets très significatif
sur le terrain et surligne c'est le
projet du tigre mk iii sur lequel les
français les espagnols et les allemands
s'accordent sur le besoin réel dans les
dix ans à venir alors que les élections
allemandes approche ces derniers
hésitent peut-être pour un problème de
répartition de charge industriel et le
risque est d'obliger les autres
partenaires à le réaliser ce en
allemagne qui pourraient alors acheter
du matériel américain conformément aux
bonnes intentions affichées par les
politiques
nous avons beaucoup de projets
industriels et capacités en commun et le
binôme franco allemand fonctionne bien
dans de nombreux domaines mais il faut
reconnaître comme le souligne bruno
rillettes dans marianne du 19 mars qu'en
matière d'armement les allemands ne sont
pas des partenaires très solide des
intérêts allemands sur les technologies
clés nationale par exemple les censeurs
ou la guerre électronique les intérêts
français visant à maintenir une
autonomie stratégique industrielle
nationale viennent se percuter
comme le remarque dominique vogel du
centre de réflexion allemand swp chaque
pays
cherche à préserver et développer ses
propres compétences technologiques sur
lesquels ils avaient si depuis des
décennies et a le sentiment souvent
justifié de faire beaucoup trop de
concessions
les deux partenaires savent que la
réalisation des grands programmes est
dorénavant hors de portée dans un cadre
uniquement nationale ils sont donc
obligés de collaborer dans une
coopération difficile dans sur le plan
de la définition technique que de la
propriété intellectuelle des brevets ou
de la répartition du cahier des charges
l'allemagne avance ses pions avec une
vision stratégie proche mais des
objectifs différents des nôtres ne
voulant pas trop dépendre de l'armement
américains français ou d'autres pays
d'europe
elle veut répartir les risques et
développer sa propre industrie de
l'armement sans pour autant freiner la
croissance rapide de son armée par
manque de fournitures des moyens requis
comme le souligne la lettre de
l'association soutien de l'armée
française du 21 mars
il est impératif de trouver un accord
pour tous les programmes à l'étude avant
juin prochain sans pour autant céder à
la pression mise par la chancelière au
conseil de défense franco allemand du 5
février
cette échéance correspond à l'entrée de
l'allemagne en période électorale pour
le renouvellement du bundestag
sachant que ce parlement s'implique
totalement dans ces opération militaro
industriel via le suivi régulier de la
gestion des programmes comme la france
prendra le relais avec sa propre
élection présidentielle il est clair que
ces attentes cumulé vont retarder de
deux ans les programmes n'ont lancé le
risque sera alors de les voir arrêter
avec des conséquences en cascade comme
il est dit dans la tribune du groupe
vauban et 25 mars face au réalisme
mercantile allemand il faut sortir d'un
altruisme français consenti au nom d'une
europe fédérale
compte tenu de leur dimension
stratégique
économique il serait normal que notre
représentation nationale s'inspire de
l'exemple allemand et s'investissent
dans un véritable suivi
key au delà des traditionnelles
auditions en commission ou de l'examen a
posteriori des documents budgétaires
ceci permettrait d'équilibrer les
relations et contrebalancer les
exigences de berlin sur lequel il faut
bien le dire
le politique a souvent tendance à
s'aligner pour des raisons éloigné du
militaire à bientôt
[Musique]